pensa a tutti che cazzo ok ciao a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fatti già oggi siamo tornati su ball boy
eravamo rimasti legati avevamo beccato
il boss di turno il primo credo boss di
ball boy che non ho ancora visto cioè sì
l'ho visto questo figo che mi arrotato
in faccia grazie dio c'è un modo per
batterlo sto zio cosa devo fare
cos'è ho aperto una cosa che sono morto
però sono convinti sono vivo come è
possibile che il boss di turno dovrebbe
essere questo qua che è un gran figo
questa è una discarica che cazzo ci
fanno i vitigni d'uva nelle discariche
cosa ne vitigno di albano c'è un
pulsante esplode tutta la c'è un bottone
grosso così zio che per me equivale a
una tetta
cioè mi va proprio di palpare la cosa
che non ci arriva ma no perché sola pin
vabbè mi sfottono perché all asp che con
la pinna e allora l'abuso la lumaca
posso usare la marca ma potevi usare la
lingua cioè la lingua come quella di
miley cyrus e la lumaca in cambio della
bomba perfetta di lo prima zio dino
questa succulenta lo ma che tu mi dai
quel palloncino di elio a deve essere
morta scusami avevo capito posso
offrirla lei buon uomo che le gradisce
a lui piace anche cruda ma no ma perché
è una lite tristezza ha ucciso la nuova
ka poverina gara in difesa grazie grazie
allo ragazzino ma che cruda quindi se
hai voglia di assaporarla adesso che
minchia mangia più veloce lui che io al
sushi devo prenderla macchia schifo
magari se non hai voglia di sbloccarmi
in faccia e meglio beccata la in faccia
bel ali e nell'occhio
cosa facciamo facciamo i palleggi ma il
pallone d'oro lo vinco io avevo io sono
messi e tu sei cristiano ronaldo bella
zio ciao e finta in realtà non serve
cioè non posso uguale rilancio
dell'altro vino a no non c'è più vino
non c'è più vino ho capito che devo
detonare la roba e va bene come faccio
non so lapin cimino solo knapp in lapin
può arrivare ovunque
non importa che tu sia un pesce o che
sia un verme importante è fare boom
sciabola stefania che dio mio
la nausea seria cioè vederle merda che
galleggiano ma che figo rossi c'è rossi
c'è forza a un'altra volta in paradiso
perfetto di massa del pala fermi perché
perché si mette a ricordare stati qui
kozuch anche problemi ai sei mai andato
da uno psicologo ricorda delle cose ma
solo un giorno ma cosa sono sono il
nonno ma se manco si regge in piedi cave
zio ma se per andare da un punto
all'altro ci metti 45 minuti prendi il
treno fai prima sei serio a svegliare
bella è bravo si è addormentato mentre
camminavano ridotto a giocare a queste
cose ragazzi ecco mandare un bel 5
ragazzi io taglio se parti quando provi
in giuro che ci mette un'ora e mezza io
per arriva da una parte all'altra si
metta una vita e adesso di nuovo posso
innaffiare il di fiore perfetto se è
bravo che si rizza come un bene pure
questo
come facciamo a una fragola è una fra
casari di epica il nonno quando reid è
un figo comunque è finito ma dai
ancora non ho capito cosa gli è successo
nel gioco però aridaje costi ragni ma
perché giardino di babe e quello al mio
cane c'è un ragno un po grosso che fa un
po schifo ti devo dare delle larve da
mangiare così estremi sono pagati ma la
mando io devo schiacciare un ragno penso
che lui possa fare la stessa cosa avete
appena visto anche se il grosso così
bravo ancora può ancora po bravo zio
no no no mi rifiuto non riesco a
comandare me stesso perché il pesce
andava bene fate qui il ragno no ragazzi
mi fa veramente schifo c'è non non lo
guarderò ragazzo dio ma sei serio chi
cazzo buongiorno niente io il suo gioco
non capisco perché tutti ridono
devo liberare il cane che in teoria ma
sarebbe tagliare la pianta
però non mi è mancato su ca
[Musica]
non ci credo non ci sto prendendo che
col neanche non l'ho fatto neanche
apposta già che ci sei fa la stessa cosa
qua va che cesta ragnatela casa casacca
bravo zio non ci credo però non ho
capito bene cosa mi serve cedono un
filare il tubo chino infilare il tubo ok
ma non so perché devo prendere l'acido i
ragazzi sto facendo le cose senza sapere
che lo sto facendo però le sto facendo
questo ragazzi un liquido corrosivo che
fa altamente male al corpo a bruttissimo
si chiama coca cola posso usarlo sulla
radice tipo si dovrei aver battuto il
boss credo è morto cesto video devastato
tutti i boss possibili immaginabili
esistenti amico mio
stringi stavano erano fare perché sono
ragno tifoso che faccia contenta e ciò
che dolci si son ritrae lo so l'amore
l'amore è bello e la scena più trash che
abbia mai visto in tv un cane cos'era
almeno ho perso il corpo da daranno
quello è un po meno quello che botta di
culo tra tutti i posti dove poter cadere
verso la finestra c'è una è vero che si
sentì fratello
qual è il mio corpo oddio mi sta
caricando di brutto male via via via via
veloce veloce veloce vai vai vai è morto
ma non è morto si parla già del
pipistrello estivo credo che d'ora in
poi ti chiamerò belletti atleti zio
no perché 66 un figo siamo davanti al
corpo quindi dovrei riuscire a prenderlo
spero perfetto per far ciò che ci stiamo
regalo recuperato grande è infatti
quello che dice ah no puoi uscire amica
pensavo fosse difficile uscire
e invece non ho non far non farlo non
fare quello che sto pensando oddio ti
ringrazio pensavo volesse infilare la
testa c'è stato rivelato ma ti droghi
neanche un abbraccio con le mani di
gianni morandi che avrebbe ucciso
non so come ci sono ragazzi o fini crede
di aver finito di livello fantastico ce
l'abbiamo fatta e sarà difficile però ci
si lavora non ci viene o no non è
possibile nonno stituto allora io sono
convinto al 600 per cento che questo non
è mio nonno ma convinto non è mio nonno
regalato sono convinti cazzo cazzo
sembra la mia vecchia prof di matematica
ragazzi è il mostro vagina dov'è mio
nonno ce l'hai preso in ostaggio per che
sembri una vagina chiodo schiaccia
chiodo bravo uno spary dalla testa e il
mio nonno questo cioè mio nonno versione
vagine va beh posso e iacoli dalla cosa
cosa c'è una rapa dentro la vagina è una
rapa geneticamente modificata con la
spada alla battaglia giusto bene abbiamo
sicuramente battuto lo zio che sei morto
sembra che assomiglio può andare su
youtube si su youtube a devo stare
attento a non mangiare le cose sono
diventò anch'io nero perfetto è un gioco
razzista devo leccargli l'occhio finché
non spara quando vedo che spara devono
stare fermo e il boss più difficile
della vita ragazze ditemi voi sono nel
combattimento contro un boss più etico
che voi abbiate mai
altro che skyrim trash della storia ci
dovrei carli l'occhio qui devo chiudere
la bocca quando mi spara cioè che cazzo
vuol dire vabbè io io non avrò altro
videogioco all'infuori di questo ragazzo
[Musica]
ho vinto è la madonna quella un buco che
non meglio non voglio sapere da che
parte del corpo sia ho vinto ragazzi
abbiamo battuto il vostro vagina non ci
posso credere che lo sta facendo ma mia
nonna in tutto questo dove cioè fa mica
niente sposo il nostro vagina è tutta
una merda
ecco come ho fatto a uscire io sono vivo
a caso eve ragazzi questo sì questo
questo luce eterna ragazzuoli miei che
finale questo è un finale d'eccezione è
anche c'è anche se non ci credo per
quanto mi intrigano sti dialoghi e una
verità devo toccarlo questo è successo a
devo fargli sputare cosa ha ingoiato un
osso era un osso veramente sto nonno
schioppa sono guardo io ci mancherebbe
tenti portiamoci the ring visto che già
che ci siamo
visto che visto che siamo in tema hai
finito arthur mico touchscreen grande
complimenti anche a test simon luca
skitsch a un ragazzo è finito ball boy
mica checco zalone pavani bagni in lis
pokémon c'è una persona che vi cognome
si chiama pokémon ragazzi miei spero che
i video vi sia piaciuto spero che la se
vi sia piaciuto durata tre episodi
neanche tanto però è stato veramente
figo all boys 1 mi piace fare valboni
spero mi sia piaciuto e cosa che si vede
che sono sotto momento è un mi piace è
incapace di facebook e con i video
patella iscrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi riuscirvi diavolo
prossimo video
e te pareva sciamano manca da ragazze